[Musik]
28 juni 2001 im betagtenzentrum eichhof
luzern wird pfleger verhaftet erst
monate später wird klar ist ein
serientäter der mindestens 22 menschen
umgebracht hat was besonders berührt ist
das eine flagge heim situation passiert
ist wo man einiges gefühl hat man könnte
auf die institution vertraue wird
umsorgt sind beachtung kripochef und das
ist selbst im urlaub da hängen ja geht
auch katar sei also bis hängt noch das
ist sich absolut
[Musik]
luzern fünfter juli 2001 im
betagtenzentrum eichhof informiert der
luzerner sozialdirektor ruedi meier über
das schier unglaubliche pfleger hat dem
eichhof neun bewohnerinnen getötet die
kriegt 7 ein schreckliches und bedauern
wenn sie ein foul an rémy zentrum ist
das so sehr sehr schlimm
und wenn sie glaubten verhängt durch das
super gau schreibers mit doch das
vermutliche ein super gau nur den
geständnissen des täters ist es zu
verdanken dass die fälle entdeckt werden
aber die kriminalpolizei hat ein problem
die zentrale problem stelle geschehen
das tier das einst auch bewies für die
jetzige hier zuschauern vor der
möglichen eigentlich nur möglich ist die
griechen sind
trainiert wurde es ist noch sechs
akteure geführt wird wir sehen
eigentlich aufgestanden ist und da trat
müsse ein serientäter der über monate
betagte patienten getötet hat wie ist
das möglich
wieso hat niemand etwas bemerkt die
eichhof heimbewohner haben fragen sie
gemerkt dass das nicht stimmen
mit dem 34 der damals 32 jährige
arbeitete seit einem halben jahr im
betagtenzentrum eichhof pflegebedürftige
und teilweise demente menschen waren in
seiner obhut
oft habe er mit ihnen über den tod
gesprochen
viele hätten den wunsch zu sterben
geäußert sagt er später
um den tod gebeten habe ihn allerdings
niemand gesteht er ein
[Musik]
erst viel später wird klar die todes
serie hat schon viel früher begonnen
bereits sechs jahre vor seiner
verhaftung hatte hier in der
seniorenresidenz am schermer in saanen
getötet der langjährige direktor zdenek
madeira stellte als 26 jährigen ein
der umtriebige pflegehelfer war beliebt
er hatte keine etwas initiieren
zum beispiel für eine personal fest
hatte da so eine spanische initiiert
tanks bord war dieser erfolg ist heute
haben sich wirklich gebäude verlassen
oder er hatte auch dass sie sind allen
größen von der tanzschule und auch sonst
vom disco wo er hat auch keine
moderation von der modenschau übernehmen
und das ganze choreographie und so
schauen dass das glaubt das was da hat
sich bitterlich guten gespräch und sagt
nichts
beliebt war auch bei einer 84 jährigen
patientin sie wurde sein erstes opfer
sie habe den sinn des lebens nicht mehr
eingesehen und vom tod gesprochen sagt
er später
[Musik]
bald für schloss er die altersschwache
frau zu töten zu erlösen
wie er später sagte er verabreichte ihr
beruhigungsmittel nimmt einen
plastiksack und faltet ihn zweimal
zusammen den sack presst er der
wehrlosen frau aufs gesicht
dann eine halbe minute später lässt er
von ihr ab aus angst wie er später
schildert die tat misslingt die frau ist
aber so schwach dass sie sich nicht mehr
äußern kann
pfleger kommt zurück nach einer woche
diesmal drückte er dem opfer einen sagt
mehrere minuten aufs gesicht
die frau erstickt
[Musik]
das zweite opfer drei tage später ein 91
jähriger mann der am rapidem
gesundheitlichem zerfall gelitten hat
man geht von einem natürlichen tod aus
wie bei der ersten tat gibt als motiv
überforderung und mitleid an
[Musik]
nach der verhaftung wird mehrmals
begutachtet gerichtspsychiater andreas
frey ortet nicht mitleid sondern
selbstmitleids als motiv für die serien
tötung für jedermann und chronisch krank
gewerkschaft ist es bekannt dass ältere
ab und zu mal die schüsse das alles
riesig aber stellt sich zum teil nicht
nur vor dass die todeslager mio
zum teil auf abseits spielten für sich
als noch gesund und intakt sich quasi
nicht können vorstellen allemal alt und
pflegebedürftig see und aus sie denn
ihre eigene wunsch war sie in die alpine
projizieren und der mitte haben sie
würden im objektive und raster von denen
handle
[Musik]
er liebte es unter menschen zu sein und
partys zu feiern bevor er sich für die
pflege laufbahn entschied jobbte er
jahrelang als assistent in einer
tanzschule
später legte in der freizeit platten auf
er genoss es als dj im mittelpunkt zu
stehen
der heutige barbetreiber rolf schubert
war ein dj kollege von extrovertierte
können ich habe relativ viel doller
bekanntschaften mit dem diskutiert und
sich seriös klartext verbrechen
zuständig im kantonsspital obwalden
machte 1996 im rahmen seiner ausbildung
zum diplom pflege ein praktikum auch
hier tötete er er habe die klagen einer
89 jährigen frau nicht mehr ausgehalten
erklärte er später
nächste station der ausbildung
pflegezentrum senats in küssnacht
auch hier machte ein praktikum erneut
beendete er das leben betagter passieren
zumeist verabreichte er eine überdosis
beruhigungsmittel und half falls nötig
mit einem plastiksack nach wieder ging
man von natürlichen todesfällen aus
[Musik]
im mai 1999 hatte die ausbildung beendet
und kehrt nach vier jahren ins betagten
heim am schermer in saanen zurück er
wird zusehend herrischer
im team werden kritische stimmen laut
[Musik]
die negative seite habe ich eigentlich
vom hörensagen weil zu mir aus service
themen seien nicht gewesen aber ich habe
meldung überhaupt dass er ziemlich
arrogant war er konnte auch besser so
hochnäsig sein und die mitarbeiter haben
sich ja sind langsam von immer gezwungen
strebt einen führungsposten an und gilt
als engagiert das sei ein typisches
profil für serientäter im pflegebereich
sagen experten
und die sind durchaus gut integriert die
hand leistungsträger funktion teil wie
sieht eine heim
sie haben also -roller wo sie auch sehr
viel vertrauen genießt und und wo sie
über das aber auch das vertrauen viel
besser missbrauchen
es sind meistens persönlichkeit und
inter mehrzahl halt doch noch unsicher
muss bildet seit start gefühl hand und
lief ich klage profikarriere versuche
man charakterlich und zur einigkeit
weitere
er tötet in immer kürzeren abständen
innerhalb von eineinhalb jahren bringt
er im heim am schermer 10 betagte
menschen um
doch jetzt entledigt er sich immer
häufiger unliebsamer patienten die ihn
kritisieren
[Musik]
also das ist ein entwickler immer mehr
außer kontrolle geraten
heute zumeist in randzeiten seiner
bevorzugten schicht danach habe er
jeweils ein schlechtes gewissen gehabt
sei aber auch erleichtert gewesen weil
in einem betagten heim häufig gestorben
wird ist der tod teil des alltags und
nichts außergewöhnliches aber in das
umfeld werden nun gerüchte laut dass in
seiner schicht auffallend viele menschen
sterben
ihm sei aber nichts aufgefallen betont
der heimleiter
wir haben auch unsere statistik wo mir
das ja schauen wie viele todesfälle wir
haben
und interessanterweise sogar nach seinem
wirken die kurve gestiegen
zudem ist es schwierig bei uns im
gegensatz zu anderen heim oder einmal
ist es schwierig
mit dass ein arzt etwas merken würde
weil wir haben ja 16 hält der 610
hausärzte bei uns können die leute hier
ein hausarzt mitbringen und bei
schwierig irgendwelche
unregelmässigkeiten war übergreifend
sind zu merken hilfe und pflege zu hause
auch als spitex praktikant konnte er das
töten nicht lassen
trude jacoba war seine vorgesetzte in
sarnen
die patienten hätten am ort aber ihr
bereitete er probleme erinnert sie sich
andere sieht er einfach und zuverlässig
sie dreht immer wieder mehr ins
kontrollieren harburger viele revier das
macht also die er gerade mit den
medikamenten um die themen immer mehr
sein sagt dass er die richtige richtet
also sehr gut rückgemeldet und dann
hätte sich einfach krank lautet die
diagnose hobby kommunale gemacht hat und
der romandie galenica geschaffen und
ihre dienste einmal mehr seine stelle
einfach nicht und mit eine situation
also als spitex pfleger tötete eines
frühen morgens eine 83 jährige frau in
ihrer wohnung der tochter richtet er
vorher aus sie können ruhig später
kommen
ich hätte mir eine ausdrückliche zeit
ich muss die presse mit dem kopf morgen
wird das siebte schockiert wenn ich die
videos auch haben wir da sind oder
stunden zu ihm
also hätte das am erfolg mit und
unbeachtet und telefon
ihre mutter ist nieminen aber ganz
friedlich gestorben
natürlich nicht dass gerade die
angehörigen nicht im haus sind aber vor
dem rat im irak ammar der acht rennen
ist verdammt wäre so etwas macht hängt
also ein bisschen machen das ist absurd
ende 2000 wird erneut im betagtenzentrum
eichhof angestellt auf der abteilung für
demenzkranke
wieder ist er konfrontiert mit patienten
die teilweise vollständig die kontrolle
über ihre körperfunktionen verloren
haben
er habe das nicht ausgehalten gesteht
später gerade demenz patienten die mit
fortschreiten der krankheit renitent und
aggressiv werden können können auch beim
personal aggressive gegen reaktionen
hervorrufen
erst kürzlich erschütterten handy
sequenzen mit demütigenden bildern von
demenzpatienten die öffentlichkeit
pflegerinnen in einem zürcher heim
hatten sie aufgenommen
[Musik]
felix baumann arbeitete 25 jahre lang
als heim arzt im betagtenzentrum eichhof
überforderung in der langzeitpflege
wurde immer wieder zum thema ganz sicher
sind fragen die ihrem wurf immer stark
verdreckt und des hundes oder gefühl vor
der überforderung aber überfordert kann
ich mein ich für nicht sondern solche
tat sondern es braucht nowitzki faktoren
persönlichkeitsstruktur sechs
lebenssituation man drin gesteckt
erst zehn wochen verschiedene faktoren
hat sondern derart schlimme tat führen
pfleger wuchs in der innerschweiz auf in
emmenbrücke und rotenburg hier
absolvierte er die primarschule nach der
scheidung der eltern sieht er als
elfjähriger mit der mutter unter
jüngeren schwester nach deutschland
später beginnt er bei der deutschen post
eine lehre als
kommunikationselektroniker bricht diese
aber ab er lässt sich zum tanzlehrer
ausbilden und kehrt mit 21 in die
schweiz zurück sein stiefvater in
deutschland habe ihn stets als versager
gesehen das habe spuren hinterlassen
sagte später in manchester vermutlich
weiter regen kunden neben der erfolg wir
dringen
sie sind steht patrick bewiesen dass
alte tochter bisky und also in dem beruf
relativ erfolglos see und das war ein
sich für ihn nur sehr schwer tragbare
ganz ganz bitter
zurück ins pflegezentrum eichhof im
januar 2001 fällt dem personal auf das
in us schicht gehäuft todesfälle
auftreten
intim kursieren nun gerüchte
zwei mitarbeitende informierenden leiter
der pflegedienste über ihre
befürchtungen
dieser recherchiert und befragt wie er
mit den todesfällen umgehe
der pfleger erwidert leichthin er habe
sich an den tod gewöhnt
mitte februar hält der leiter in us
personal wo sie fest intuitiv habe ich
das gefühl etwas im sozialbereich stimmt
nicht es ist sehr wichtig dass er in
nächster zeit beobachtet wird
auffälligkeiten in seinen äußerungen und
seinem verhalten sind sofort zu melden
über diese notiz informiert er auch heim
arzt felix baumann
kurze zeit später wechselt der leiter
der pflegedienste den job flexi pass in
die gedanken und sorgen informiert er
hat einfach der gedanke vom dezember
hall mit demnach stellt vielleicht eher
unter todesfall eine kleine weg von mir
ist das zuerst als verschnitt denkbar
ich habe den krankengeschichten von
einer patientin verstorben sind normal
ab morgen haben wir gedanken darüber
gemacht habe als einzelfall wie keinem
fall eigentlich sehr ungewöhnliches
feststellen
überhaupt ist sie gedanken dass
mitarbeiter da könnte ich los genau auf
die todesfall von mir eigentlich
undenkbar und so ganze und aussprechen
sie im mai sterben einmal zwei frauen
trotz unklarer todesursache verzichtet
heim arzt baumann auf eine meldung
er habe nichts besonderes feststellen
können sagt er später
euro wobei mir gemacht sie nicht weil
ich sie darum kein zwingender grund für
meldung
zudem ist sich auf erden oxide gemeldet
wie man weiß dass er meldet polizei
immer mit umtrieb verbunden sind wo sich
überhaupt nicht mit der tour arbeit und
hier beginnt sofort im tatort
übereinstimme das pflegeheim ist
vertrauens institution der flagge heim
dankbar dass man lüthi muss hegen und
pflegen und das marine bis zum statur
also die grundhaltung vor allem ist das
gegenseitige vertrauen die flaggen
mentalität auf der andere seite spielt
sich aber wichtige rolle das time leiter
und leitende arzt ein skandal dass sie
angst davor haben dass dort bis nach
uster trinkt wo die ganze institution
könnten fragt sie und tritt die
phänomene ist natürlich die angst vor
strafverfolgung polizei im haus hat dass
da plötzlich personen bezugspersonen
anstimmen dass das plakat verlässlich
ist das spielt auch meter große rolle
mitte mai verdächtigen zwei
teamkolleginnen pfleger a starke
beruhigungsmittel entwendet zu haben um
ihn zu überführen markieren sie den
pegelstand etwas später der beweis dass
schicht wurde beruhigungsmittel
verabreicht ohne dass es verschrieben
worden war
die beiden klägerinnen machen meldungen
beim heim arzt das undenkbare muss jetzt
bedacht werden was ich eigentlich als
hat die ware mehr harmonie könnte dass
das medikament feld ohne sorge vor
deiner bei der flecken der körper und
ihre müsse feststellen dass der
todesfall mitarbeiter vom er aber nicht
anders eigene note als das duo im
zusammenhang mit einem todesfall muss
vorhanden sie wieder lässt felix baumann
ein wochenende verstreichen
doch am montag elfter juni 2001 macht er
meldung der luzerner sozialdirektor
ruedi meier reagiert umgehend wo wir
noch hat eine der fall ist kritisierte
da nicht irgendwie habe ich das gemerkt
deutsche disney damit möglichst schnell
hilfe und unterstützung
und dieser fall hat das not polizei sie
und ich hatte einfach angst dass man
möglichst schnell polizeilich schaltete
die kriminalpolizei beginnt mit den
ermittlungen gegen anliegen aber nur
indizien vor
beweise gibt es keine ein dilemma
die zeit drängt der täter könnte wieder
zuschlagen
der einzige nachhaltig die chance ist
klar vor die situation im ganzen also
mehr service hätte die sander geteilt
werden staus verantwortlich und die
betreffenden personen und realisiert das
ist der einzig der nachhaltige schutz
alles andere haben können
anstatt in der medizin also meant
konkret aber bewachen diskutiert aber
micha nicht unmöglich sondern also das
objekt bewachen sollte jetzt kontrolle
machen oder polizistin flächen dahinter
noch etwas daher macht sich so nicht
verhindern
der einzige schutz ist daher mit
hochdruck an einer mitgliedschaft zum
mittel steuerung ist klar warum das ist
der einzige und meinen körper machen
wenige tage später stirbt erneut eine
patientin sie wird obduziert
der befund entlastet weist jedoch auf
eine natürliche todesursache hin
im zuge der ermittlungen fragt die
polizei auch bei der spitex in sachen
nach und stehen seit tagen verhaftet
bevor die sieht monika volk und es sei
dankbar dass mir für das schicksal
betroffen sie die mit dem todesfall
und die möchte momente hat dank das ist
nicht möglich das komitee
am abend des 27 juni 2001 stirbt erneut
eine patientin im eichhof
er habe die 76-jährige nicht gemocht sie
habe ihn ständig kritisiert sagt der
täter später
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen lässt kripo chef
daniel bussmann den pfleger verhaften
obwohl er keine stichhaltigen beweise
hat den großen arbeite 60 81 5 cent alle
konkreten auftrag von risiko waren und
alle sicherstellen mit befragen
und da ist die mit der notruf der ak 16
worauf der zugang ist ein versehen
husten du verkauf schon einen ruf
erarbeitet hat sich widerstandslos noch
anstellen alex ohne eine frage mit dem
der husten suche gemacht die zwei
medikamenten eine sicherstellung und
steuerbarkeit und bei der befristung der
liegt gestanden heute veröffentlicht
gestanden gekommen der sohn des letzten
opfers ist schockiert
sechs tage zuvor hatte er seiner mutter
nach besucht ich bin nur wenige tag
vorher mini mutter geburtstag am 22 juni
und ich bitte ein bit systeme sind
miteinander um cosimo und bei mittlerer
bangkoks es ist ein sonniger tag sehr
mit geschwärzt
nach der verhaftung wird einvernommen
aber seine anfängliche geständnis
bereitschaft lässt schnell nach
der lauffreudige danke ich hatte eher
den euro realisiert was eigentlich
unterzeichnet worden was eigentlich
gemacht und dann von außen vor zu machen
kooperiert den bloggern aktiv und ist
das auch wieder lag worauf aktive trixi
inclusive sehr durch eine verrückt
werden also identisch sind
ich danke der morde jungs richtig sie
ihnen raten die serien tötungen
medizinisch nachweisen
das war seine aufgabe gerichtsmediziner
rudolf hauri analysierte die
krankengeschichten von 142 patienten die
während us arbeitszeiten gestorben waren
seinen kriminalistischen blick entging
anders als dem geheim ärzte nichts muss
gh einen komatösen zustand wo eine
vergiftung denkerin zum teil es in der
unterlage sogar schon billiger für
betriebe wohl was sie ist wies in der fr
giftig ist zum teil aber gut und einzige
im gesicht geschrieben
sie sind im beton holz sogar wo eine
mechanische gaudi weltkrieg im sinn von
bürger- oder vom druck schließt raúl
hängt gerichtsmediziner hauri scheute
bei der spurensuche keinen aufwand
er ordnete fünf exhumierungen an bei 40
krankengeschichten schaute er genauer
hin und wieder eine vielzahl von 22
als gut auch dass hacker das sind
natürliche todesfälle sind gewaltsame
todesfälle
trotzdem spielt im sterben die acht
todesfälle mit einer sitzen durften zum
teil einfach so mangelhaft ski oder
unvollständig das nicht klappt können
diese aber wohl trotzdem ist der verlauf
auffällig sie die personen sind relativ
schnell gestorben sind nur den
eigentlichen in der s kurve zeigt aber
doch nicht
obwohl und die cfl bin ich zum schluss
kogler auf grundlage sind natürlich das
feld weil sich nicht mehr an jede
einzelne tat erinnern kann wird die
todesursache in acht fällen für immer
offen bleiben
die untersuchungsergebnisse werden
ausgerichtet am 11 september 2001 den
medien präsentiert die anschläge in new
york verdrängen die größte serien tötung
der schweiz aus den schlagzeilen
und auch die frage wieso der täter so
lange unentdeckt bleiben konnte
großes medieninteresse dagegen beim
prozess vor kriminalgericht dreieinhalb
jahre später im januar 2005 wird er aus
platzgründen in einer mehrzweckhalle in
emmenbrücke durchgeführt
nur gerade sechs stunden dauert die
verhandlung am schluss verließ der
angeklagte eine erklärung
er sagt er habe gott gespielt und über
leben und tod entschieden
das sei nicht richtig gewesen die
angehörigen bittet er um entschuldigung
[Musik]
der staatsanwalt plädiert auf mord in
fünf fällen und auf 17 vorsätzliche
tötungen als strafmildernd
berücksichtigt er die geständnis
bereitschaft erfordert 17 jahre
zuchthaus
der staatsanwalt hat cbc erlag das hat
in der fachkreise durchaus überraschung
hervor kurve will ein staatsanwalt eher
am oberen an die mieten auch länder und
wenn es um 2 20 fach ethik oder sogar
monate geht dann ist es sehr naheliegend
dass man die lebenslängliche haft das
kriminalgericht folgt dem staatsanwalt
nicht und verhängt die höchsten strafe
lebenslange zuchthausstrafe wegen 22
fachen mordes
im strafmaß her
lebenslänglich kann ich nachvollziehen
ich habe das akzeptiert ich persönlich
einen antrag stellt kwh faktoren höhere
gewichte zugunsten vermarktet umfassende
geständnis bereitschaft wo es als der
strafverfolgungsbehörde erlaubt hat
sachen tätige oft stecken wo sucht mit
die drinnen aufgedeckt werde
legt berufung ein der viele medien wegen
findet der prozess vor obergericht ein
jahr später im saal des luzerner
grossrat stadt auch am ende dieser
verhandlung entschuldigt sich für seine
taten und beteuert sein bedauern
[Musik]
das obergericht befindet das a nicht in
allen 22 fällen sondern nur sieben mal
besonders skrupellos getötet habe an der
lebenslänglichen strafe allerdings hält
es fest
bislang ist in den allermeisten fall
wenn die rückfallgefahr besteht wenn
auch in kurz verhalten im strafvollzug
sich lebenslang lebenslang sondern sind
15 jahre freiheitsstrafe für den sohn
des letzten opfers aber bleiben viele
fragen offen haben die behörden
fahrlässige handelt wurde die mutter als
köder benutzt oder allenfalls sogar no
mehreren nötige in kauf genommen und ich
habe das nie mit dem vorwerfen aber es
ist mir wichtig dass das ab klagt wird
an sie klagt durch behörden und
heimleitung werden vom vorwurf der
fahrlässigen tötung freigesprochen den
heim arzt spricht erst das obergericht
frei auch eine frühere meldung hätte den
tod des letzten opfers nicht zwingend
verhindern können so die begründung der
marke zeigt dass ich sehr lang
viele gedanken familie paul k
ich wäre mit schnellsprecher sechs
zuerst mit kollegen 6 mit dem leiter vom
zentrum sechs einander person und ich
weiß ich kann also einen blick
deponieren der fall des todes pflegers
hat viel ausgelöst um überforderung zu
vermeiden werden für das pflegepersonal
vermehrt supervisionen angeboten
allgemein habe laut behörden die
aufmerksamkeit zugenommen in
pflegeheimen werden heute todesfälle mit
unklarer ursache häufiger gemeldet
aber welche situationen sind einfach
wurde und sie hat immer wieder neue
löcher mit oder sind sich alle durch
krisen in der meeting im bereich der
pflege also vor dem hintergrund geht es
dass ich immer des lateins risiko
ich glaube der fuß das natürlich bewusst
sie mittlerweile geschäftlich und das
schwieriger erhöht sondern als recht
witzig dass der betroffene die tat
eigentlich angerichtet hat über jahre
hinweg nicht nur den opfern und ihren
angehörigen hat der todes kläger aus der
innerschweiz viel leid zugefügt auch die
pflegenden hat er bis ins innerste
getroffen das kombiniert einfach klasse
dass ich eine sehr sehr lange nachhaltig
und wenn wieder ein geschäft vor dem
feld wurden ich habe immer gemerkt die
wunder sind monitor haut obwohl man auch
daran mit dem team coaching mit
betreuten suppression hätte man das
arbeitet aber sitzt das sieht so das ist
das ist einfach das vertrauen eines
besonderen nähe von der bloßen von der
berufsgruppe das ist jetzt dass das ist
das wird einem so wild
[Musik]
serientäter dürfte 2016 aus der haft
entlassen werden psychiater geben ihm
gute prognosen vorausgesetzt arbeitet
nie mehr im pflegebereich
[Musik]